Barack's you look great today thank you
so much so she showed up in like a tiny
little fur thing a little velvet skirt
that's short it's pretty short you like
to usually say this like if I'm wearing
something that's up to my neck he's like
oh and the low-cut shirt with the big
boobs I'm like this is a pretty big
fight I'd say you had anything well cut
on I said your skirt was short that's
true my skirt is very short already
looking like a thing if you were in a
John Steinbeck novel you'd get killed by
accidentally by a [ __ ] guy petty
it's like 85 degrees outside - I don't
know why I'm wearing fur in velvet
that's okay
well you again it's very very short and
you got thigh-highs on - yeah what do
you think about those I don't mind
they're comfortable and their knee socks
oh is that right a Frenchy what's the
difference the length my eyes go to the
top of the thigh literally me versus I I
see yeah so thigh eyes is what that
Pilate was masturbating in in the
cockpit absolutely you know that knee
socks
no he won't look not as silly and knee
socks but in thigh highs he looked a bit
ludicrous couldn't have been behaving
more poorly on the job did you hear
about this guy mm-hmm he was he got
fired because he was uh they did fire
him well I guess I'm sorry you're right
suspend at home yeah because he was
caught via photos masturbating in the
cockpit of a British Airways always if
he put up hooked him himself he posted
pictures of himself masturbating yeah it
was like Italy didn't post him I don't
know where he posted him he must have
sent him or they were lost in the cloud
or somebody ratted him out or something
I don't know because he put his his
thigh height up socks on the steering
wheel and his bottom of his balls and
top of you know like the you kind of see
his taint and bottom of his [ __ ] and
ball I really examine these pictures
yeah photos the guy but the guy was
laying back in the chair and he was
really trying to show everything yeah
and he's got to get fired for that he
can't jerk off an icon pin you can't not
with thigh-highs I know and we saw his
pants and his shoes - my favorite part
with his shoes
the empty shoes if his pants are off or
they were folded next to or something he
just like tousled him down and they were
next to him like if the belt was still
in them you know what I mean you could
obviously tell the copilot had just left
because he just quickly took his pants
down oh it's the oops you caught me luck
and start yeah it started jerking off
hmm but god bless him I guarantee you he
has a system when that guy comes back
where he could just throw the magazine
and slip the pants on immediately yeah
he probably care about the shoes to the
guy won't notice when he sits down you
just slip your shoes back on I bet a
pilot takes his shoes off on the floor
by the way those socks you can only tell
stockings are like man's dress socks
from the bottom they kind of look the
same no I think I think stockings are a
little bit more transparent they're a
little bit more see to me know who's
gonna notice that the [ __ ] dark
cockpit I would notice you might by feel
to caress his feet well he's got his
ankles wrapped around my cheeks sausage
feed right would you like a man's feet
in your face no I would hate a man's
sock foot with his dress tight dress
socks on rockin foot have you dated a
weird guy who's like asked you some
weird fetish Ethio no hmm I got to tell
you something I'm kind of a weird fetish
person really well not always but I do
like feet men's feet I like feet I've
heard that from a few different women
that it that they like men's feet that's
more of a submissive thing you suck toes
I have been a toe sucker before oh good
you have to get somebody else to be into
it because it's not fun if you're
sucking somebody's toes there's like oh
god why the [ __ ] are you sucking would
you be like that Jim if Roxy started
sucking your toes did you be like Roxy
that's so gross and weird times somebody
who you know it's a weird thing for a
man to say to a woman like for women to
say hey you won't like my feet yeah but
it's for a guy to say to a woman because
most women are not into feet and see
yeah if you just put them in a face and
if they like it they'll do it by the way
you can you can see photos these people
are gonna want to know you can see
photos of Roxy on her Twitter at Roxy
stryer she's also on afterbuzz TV and
screen junkies
and she's she's got herself in she's
always been hot but she's gotten herself
in very good shape lately and she's
become a big fan of the spandex unitard
yeah I wear a lot of unitards that's for
sure and you can also see me on your
snapchat because I I jacked it for the
day and I'm apologizing in advance for
the dick pics you guys have received
after me posting a little bit of a
provocative picture of myself I'm just
kind of you know when you when you're
trying to be a hot girl so you kind of
open your mouth a little bit you're like
you know like little kissy face kind of
thing because you think that's sexy in
my mind I was like oh yeah this will
look hot this will get all the boys
lathered up on Jim and Sam show on
snapchat yeah see so you like men's feet
when did you first realize like guys
feet this is weird because you keep
saying men's feet and it's just feet oh
just feel like women's feet - I guess so
be kind of circle ladies toes I did I
did suck a lady's toes her name was Emma
I think we were like 13 years old and
that's how I realized that I liked toes
it was one of those we were kind of
laying on my couch watching a movie and
we were young and she was like do you
want to suck on my toes and I was like
okay yes sure yeah because it wasn't
like a sexual thing at the time it was
more I don't know she why she asked me
maybe it was sexual for her sure was and
then she was like you want me to suck on
your toes and I was like I guess so and
she didn't I was like that was cool at
least six no bigger way bigger I'm an
eight yeah I'm sure so for a short
person do you mind that they're bigger
no yeah there's the photo with the mouse
yeah yeah there's a little bit kind of
trying to be sexy right like casual oh
I'm kind of cute that's where the big
toe goes and your friends suck each
other's toes for how long
just once yeah it was just one time and
then I switched over to men's toes
because then I'm not into women idled
for a little bit but it wasn't my thing
really what situation do you like to be
when you suck a guy's toes like is he
dominating you are you having sex or
like while he's on the couch do you like
to be ignored while you suck his toes
no no not ignored you got to be in the
heat of things like you got to be going
for it and just not a submissive thing
no it's kind of like on my it seems in
the opposite direction but on your way
to
a [ __ ] like some people will start at
the top and then go down but you can
also start at the bottom and then do you
lick between the toes and when you're
blowing him do you start going I started
at the bottom now I'm here
honestly so Hitler on a shitty black
said when you did it
he smiled so big do you like so proud of
himself before I even got it was very
happy what a cornball
yes it's more of like a suck pole motion
I see you take the whole foot and suck
all the toes are just each toe no not
the whole foot right okay do you like
the bottom the arch of the foot and
heels
mark more toes okay October so now how
do you like the guy to behave while
you're doing it dead silent and you're
sucking their toes you get really
concerned I would say something sexy if
you're sucking my toes like oh this
makes me feel like I have five little
pricks down there Roxy I think you just
found which piggy went to the market
this little piggys about to go
wee-wee-wee all in your hair let's see
okay so do you like your Bush is him on
your face pushes his toes on my face
like kicked me no I took you no no just
press it yeah I haven't sucked that many
toes no I guess I would try it a foot on
my face it doesn't seem that far away
from my mouth if it's my cheek okay you
just hope you feel you've chosen your
mouth yeah I do for them clean obviously
a lot of guys have shitty like hangnails
and stuff like that a man's foot is not
traditionally the most well taken care
of thing yeah you got to get pedicures
as a man you got to do it especially if
you're gonna put your toes in somebody's
mouth ummm back to Boston in a long time
that's true Wow I guess I should be more
into the dirty toes I got a with my
roots you know okay man's foot
that's an interesting fetish Roman I
have got four feet you know and see as
many women because women have like a
really weird reaction they [ __ ] hate
feet everybody
you're a very assertive person in life
though do you I do you ever get
submissive yeah definitely like it oh
you have to because when you're somebody
who's in the industry and you're working
your ass off and you always have to be
yelling and yelling and fighting with
everybody
sometimes when you're with somebody you
just want to be like alright take me I
have nothing left but yeah do whatever
you want someone spank you please talk
dirty
what kind of thing would you say like
what like who you've been misbehaving
yes like that just like with that voice
yeah yeah yeah that was your best one
yet I'm not even kidding right done that
before sure and they like that yeah Oh
someone didn't do their chores and
studies why do they have a lazy of a
hint of a Scottish accent Scottish she's
spanking her in the moment why is he
saying it like that they're spanking
like why didn't you do her studies she's
still in school um no she's uh what
happened no she's she's not going for
her masters
oh yeah it's perfect sense she's going
for her master's and you do have to do
your studies
mister it's important that's true but
she was unable to because she was
arrested for drunk driving
is that right yes I'll spank her yes yes
she was behaving like she plowed into a
family and killed three people that were
any kids she'd kill any kids just two in
the car yes father and two kids hit her
harder she gets a spanking
yeah so part of your role play is that
you'll give the woman a spanking for
shattering those dreams yeah killing two
children in a drunk-driving yes she woke
up in a drunk tank the whole thing
studies that's such a fun fantasy yeah
are you getting turn on Roxy definitely
I'm wishing that I was the driver in the
scenario do you have nice feet are your
feet awful they're okay okay yeah if he
can go I like a certain kind of foot
it's not a maniac for it I prefer like a
nice-looking foot that's clean but a
little you know let's see what we got
okay okay
I'll be honest so ya actually gonna put
a feeder paint in my toes a little
better so that you know they're like
normal feet we look at from your angle
they're like normal no there they are
Roxy's got her feet up there nice she's
actually very nice yeah they're a nice
color too they're cool you know mind a
little stench as long as it's not dirty
as long as they're not like [ __ ] like
I've been walking barefoot and my dog
hairs on them [ __ ] nasty just walk
through excrement with my bare feet on
yeah one girl had talked to me about
sucking her toes he was just chatting
about it but I knew she had roaches it
was just gross in her house where else
would her roaches big it sounds like the
roaches were living in her no in her in
her feet and her in her house but I mean
like I just kept thinking her walking
around Roach eggs I'm like I can't suck
those probably did - no I didn't we just
talked about it no I mean she probably
did oh yeah yes yeah I like him clean
clean but like right from the gym in
socks
he said no though you said straight up I
will not do this no we would talk you
into through text it wasn't like one of
those things over there in my face why
would a pig exactly
nobody wants a suck your [ __ ] roach
egg [ __ ] [ __ ] nasty it seems like
it must have been difficult to date you
Roxy because every every time you come
in here it's like your experience has
happened so early you know what I mean
you were [ __ ] second toes at 13 sure
when did you give up that mouth of yours
yeah yeah 13 also 13 she's blowing a
dude oh my god how old was he he was 13
also which is better which is better
because you know we're learning together
and that's why I did it
plus you know what it's like to suck at
13 your host dick now so that's your
everybody else's dick is great compared
like I'll still remember that first 13
year old penis so everybody else has a
leg up on that motivated you to do it at
that age okay
so I had never kissed a guy before and I
wanted to be really good at something
like that movie with Drew Barrymore
never been kissed where she blows the
thirteen-year-old yeah that's what she
did I think this is my dream that was
Kevin Bacon in the woodsman
that's the movie but in my mind I was
thinking all right so everybody else is
good at kissing you know everybody's had
their first kiss he won't know if I suck
at sucking so I gotta try that and then
I'll be the girl who gave a great
[ __ ] even if I gave a crappy [ __ ]
okay
did you give him a good one it was
amazing it was great how long did it
last
I think way too long I think maybe there
was like you know he was a little
nervous and there was some like not
gonna rod no he did he did but it was
like he had to jerk off a little bit and
then I would suck his dick and then a
jerk off a little bit they weren't that
good at it I was better than any of the
other thirteen-year-old girl you're a
toothy goose I think I probably didn't
get it you had to be the best by default
because none of the other 13 year olds
were blowing dudes I was the best
[ __ ] he ever had had you were the
first yes I was okay so when he when he
when he came did he tell you I knew how
did you find out I knew because I knew
because all of a sudden there was
something in my mouth and I had read I
think it was either Teen People one of
those things that swallowing was a lot
sexier so I remember I like took a 17
people yeah no joke it was in one of
those teen magazines and one of the
pieces that somebody had written about
giving their boyfriend a [ __ ] so I
took a step back and I remember I
breathed in deep through my nose and I
like very to impress him made like a big
gulp sound so somebody swallow your jism
that way gon I got blown like Jim Nabors
[Laughter]
but I thought that's what he wanted to
hear and so he looked at me and goes why
did you do that and you're like I can't
get it up now and I said what do you
what do you mean why did I do that cuz I
read it somewhere and I think I just
said that and he was like you're
supposed to spit that out
and I was so embarrassed he couldn't
have been be embarrassed we didn't know
that it's soap he's at 13 she just
became the [ __ ] eater in school
yeah everyone that he did right and she
swallowed and she swallows so you were a
little we were you doing a little bit as
the [ __ ] then well no because after that
after then going upstairs and breathing
into my brother's face I was known as a
lesbian cuz he spread that rumor hard
your brother did right that's right I
remember you telling me that so I was no
longer you know pierced you have a
sister is he younger or older
my sister's younger by seven years so if
your younger sister came to you at 13 in
your 20 she was like Jim Jim and she
accidentally belched it was come on her
breath how would you react I wouldn't be
shocked if I'd be mine I'd be this guy
I'd be disgusted to smell anything on
any one of my family's breath it would
creep me out
yes breath well remember it wasn't an
accident though I went upstairs to
talent right so what happened okay so
this guy below so you have a foot fares
nothing you don't that many faces you
know I really don't I'm pretty normal
like I like to have fun I like to try
new things I like feet you didn't like
had to be something you tried doing I
think so I'm not that into too much but
stuff do you like you're too much but
stuff you like your butt kissed and
played with can you handle that a little
bit but you know some guys get really
they try to get really aggressive and
and treat it like it's your vagina and
it's not like I'm gonna put my four
fingers in and I like to twist and turn
it like I caught the egg beater to beat
some eggs time to make some breakfast
you say that when you're doing yeah yeah
yeah I'm like your stomach I'm gonna
make an omelet girls just get turned on
at me it's time for breakfast in bed
baby yeah I wouldn't think that's what
he meant if he said I want to make an
omelet I would think you were gonna jizz
and like spread it on somebody's back
and then maybe had a couple peppers yeah
I call that curing the burns I like I'm
playing it like burn burn lotion
man out of thoughts no you did
you did okay you like a little bit of
butt stuff but not much
yeah okay how many knuckles in oh it's
more about it learn about one less about
the length and more about too much
thickness no oh length is okay like
these little skinny woman fingers I
could probably get about four knots in
but a man's hand
Sam Skeletor fingers you could get the
whole thing yeah I could do the egg
beater and she wouldn't even know the
Greek guy maybe half a thumb not down
the Greek guys they do have big hands I
see I see
they thick hairy what so it's always a
difficult for like to start dating guys
because when they become very insecure
at the fact that you had like fun
experiences early that they hadn't had
yet that's intimidating for a young man
I think because I've had sex with such a
small amount of people which is actually
surprising to most people more than five
yeah so not such a small amount of
people but compared to what you would
think talking to me I'm very open about
it people will probably think I had sex
with like 30 40 whatever John no
commonly misinterpreted fact about Roxy
she does indeed not give up the vagina
very often right yeah and I think it's a
Jewish thing to give a lot more blow
jobs and for some reason guys are not as
intimidated by a girl who's given a lot
of [ __ ]
I'm more intimidated by somebody's had a
lot of sex partners I see guys you date
do you tell them about your past or no
oh anything no no they want to know some
guys don't want to know right some guys
don't want to know no they don't want to
know nothing they don't want to know
they want to think they're the first
ones in there yeah it depends who
because sometimes you know you'll start
dating a guy and he'll ask you a
question and very quickly realize he
can't handle the answer what's the
question he'll ask something like am I
the biggest they'll try to do it more
casually than that like so have you ever
had sex on the beach and I'm like yeah
and they're like with who and when and
how long did it last and how many time
more importantly what island where you
are actually Jamaica like oh no oh
shucks [ __ ] a black guy and I have have
you yeah a giant took her no it was it
was big it wasn't giant the biggest
you've ever had no no it wasn't
and once I went black I did come back
you did I yeah I did go back he was he
was a smoke show though he was really
high and this big dude and I was kind of
expecting it to be a little bigger but
it was a good size like doesn't tear me
up doesn't make me nervous sighs so the
guy care that you had it's like a black
I don't know some guys do care really
yeah and that's kind of a bummer and
that shows like all right that this
isn't just intimidated I think it's more
being threatened by the myth of oh no
this guy probably did so much better
than I'm gonna do if you were dating
Roxie Jim are there any instances where
you would want her to bring up that fact
yeah every time we had sex
tell me how great it was and how much
she enjoyed it you wouldn't want her to
tell you it wasn't that big would you
well I would want to be truthful it's
got to be truthful it's not fine if
they're lying cuz it's like we're both
adults like if we were having sex and I
was like oh my god you're so much bigger
than the black guy i fuked would that be
sexy to you no not if it wasn't true no
for what okay he would honestly dad Jim
would probably prefer if you told them
how much smaller he was oh okay yeah a
little bit of humiliation can be fun but
it's got to come from a real place right
right have you enjoyed doing that you're
not looking for like a second I have
role-playing no my thing is fine to him
and embarrass my dick so I don't need to
be some guys like dick humiliation I
don't need that right I just need you to
talk about possibly but other things did
you ever have a guy wanna uh want you to
kick him in the nuts mm-hmm never
anything like that that's a fetish for
some guys oh yeah have you ever had that
not a guy I wanna be kicked in there I
don't I don't get it at all but I've
seen it happen but I I couldn't be
further from George Carlin said to my
friend he said keep kicking him in the
nuts friend of mine just said you're one
friend and my friend thought it was
apparent was something Carlin says to
everyone the [ __ ] Airport that one
wrestler who likes to get walked on like
with high heels on his face
I don't know X mark was telling us about
this there's that one Tony Atlas oh you
remember Tony Atlas or said the black
Superman huh he liked he has like the
craziest foot fetish he loves yeah he
loves women to walk on his face with
high heels yeah he loves getting kicked
with high heels and abused
does he like bare feet to yo yeah he
loves all of it he loves all of it and
he licked dirty shoes I'm sure he will
oh my well he's obsessed with that so
crazy shoes that she was real hot I
wouldn't care what she looked like she'd
be lucky if I [ __ ] touched her clean
shoes no hopping about a couple
dominator she's asked me to kiss their
shoes so I'll pick the [ __ ] top of it
like just to get to it but nowhere near
where it can get dirty it's not my thing
I don't get that you can't even feel it
you can't feel your shoe it's about the
humiliation when naughty boy likes shoes
down just take them off [ __ ] sit down
[Laughter]
I've been naughty and he puts on that
special belt and you like yes it's
interesting okay so you uh you're a bit
of a that's just something I don't hear
from a lot of women that's cool somebody
has a question for Roxy if you want to
call in call eight six six nine six nine
one nine six I know that we have a new
sound clip
Roxy Strider is here with us is there a
queue for the new sound clip
yeah like if I if someone interrupts me
I'm gonna go like this
okay so what would you like what would
be in Gemini were laughing about that
story all day because yeah we were
together we were together all day
yesterday driving from podcast a podcast
we were laughing at bill burrs Bob Kelly
story all day to the point where when
just got home from work because she was
here working when Jess got home last
night to the hotel
the first thing I had to do was tell her
the Bilborough Bob Kelly story yeah I
loved it I was enjoying it quite a bit
don't hold it very well what do you mean
I don't mean to interrupt you [ __ ] our
friend Bob Kelly shouted that at dead
Bill Berlin the sidewalk yeah that's so
great yeah this is the best please load
that one crumbly oh yeah
eight six six nine six nine one nine six
nine Sam in Virginia
you're on Jim Norton and Sam Roberts hey
what's up buddy
I have a pretty interesting question
what what advice does Roxy have for a 24
year old virgin performing oral sex on
his girlfriend for the first time are
you a 24 year old virgin
I am Wow and you're and you haven't even
performed oral sex on anybody it's like
the level of versions that I currently
am what astound you how did you how did
you make it 24 years without ya doing
anything how did you meet this girl is
there a girl our mutual friend but a
person just my nature out there that
much I'm crazy when it just it just
doesn't happen and then as the years go
on like you get more like if it doesn't
happen in high school then you go okay
well you know maybe I'll go to college
maybe I'll do this it'll happen there
and then the longer it doesn't happen
the more you're just kind of like okay
it hasn't happened and it just doesn't
so first of all you cannot become
content with it are you just hold on you
just jumped in while Roxy oh no Danny
let me cut
[Laughter]
so you can't tell her you can't tell her
that you've never performed oral sex so
you think at 24 if a guy whispers to you
right now he goes down on you because we
wouldn't say to her yeah how did you
tell her how did she know that well it
was just like throughout the progression
of our relationship I want it to be
completely honest with her because there
would be nothing more humiliating than
you know getting to that point and then
at that exact been in your relationship
doing for four months exactly she was in
another state and I'm a truck driver
what do you want from me you have a
really long tongue how's it gonna reach
all the way over there yeah yeah so what
it's like the first time you've seen her
in a while
that's one of the perks of being a truck
driver is when I go off duty I can kind
of take my off-duty time anywhere I want
so every other time I go off duty I go
see her so let me ask you something
you'd never like you how did you tell
her that you've never given oral sex
before licked a box as it were yeah
how'd you tell you've never been bean
flickin Donny Yeah right eight in the
couch yeah you've never gone muff-diving
yeah how did you explain to her that
you'd never put your nose where it
stinks I told her that I had never had
sex before it was kind of I didn't
really even have to mention the fact
that I hadn't you've never gotten mouth
fish in either
haha no mouth no no being so the advice
I would give any you're asking Roxy but
I would say what you gotta do is you go
from the side and you grab both lips in
between your teeth and you tear left and
right and make the yummy noise that
drives our crazy
yummy noise
oh that's so great now I get it
so you almost have the whole vagina in
your mouth yeah and you're high and
you're just shaking it like a dog in his
toy
yeah and it's rough oh yeah and you kind
of sideways she's on her stomach and you
opened her legs from the back that's
cool and you got your nose Preston or
theis and you talk like that and then
you bite the lips yeah that's gonna
affect the yummy noise oh [ __ ] sexy
rock you tell how would you tell him for
real how would you help this guy so I
think because you said that you haven't
had sex with anybody doesn't mean you've
never had oral sex no doesn't mean
you've never done it so I would pretend
that you had and just own it pretend
like you know exactly what you're doing
make sure you don't leave out the clip
if you don't know where that is you got
a Google at first you should look at
something good you google it you flick
your [ __ ] tongue on it and you write
some letters you know how to satisfy a
girl right yeah don't make those noises
Roxie Roxie staining the chair as she
listens to chip yeah I'm sorry Roxie go
ahead honestly the confidence you had to
call in the show means that you will
have some confidence so down down there
so you know you watch porn enough times
you know what you're [ __ ] doing a lot
of people say calling Jim Norton and Sam
Roberts is like going down on a woman
yeah being in here with you guys feels
like I'm getting somebody going down on
me right now right
what guys done wrong when they've gone
down on you you know same area too much
too aggressive too rough oh good no
sound bite what would you say is the
biggest mistake first-timer can make
when it comes to performing all don't
ask if showers hum yeah that's the my
least favorite thing right
yes are you there yet are you there yet
almost yeah that's what I do I don't say
have you coming up but I go like like
every five minutes I just look up and go
almost what you get so much pressure on
you you feel like you're doing something
wrong and then all of a sudden you're
out of the moment and you're like god
damn it like stop [ __ ] asking me that
question what I do I just think my
talking I'm like a hum for chipper
Comfort chipper if you really play into
this it might work for something come
for chipper I look up every three
minutes and I go quicker or slower
quicker slower okay good and then I go
back to work you guys should just make
hand signals then right yeah I do I spy
with my right arm that means hurry up my
back hurts
yeah you have to tell him that before
cuz I wouldn't get that hand signal I
wouldn't know what that meant
are you nervous Sam ha that's what he
says to himself every morning right
before we go on the air Brady it's time
to change well I go I gotta tell myself
this so I don't go in there looking like
I'm fumbling alright right you probably
will it's your first time doing
something you know what I mean like
you're probably going to be dog [ __ ] at
it no Sam it's hard to really [ __ ] that
up I mean it's it's an easy thing to
navigate no its enjoy it and fine and
tell her that you want her to tell you
if she wants something and let her know
it's okay to say I want this or I want
that you know women never say yes and
Sam you're not gonna you're not gonna
marry this woman this is the woman that
you're doing everything for the first
time on just use her and maintain the
relationship user as like your litmus
test practice [ __ ] yeah yeah licker
toes do everything - I know like I tell
every like all of my close friends that
know this about me I always tell them
this like I'm just not the type of
person that can you just use a woman
like that you don't know what you could
do you never even ate in a [ __ ] before
your date there for months user how your
goody two-shoes yeah stop you're afraid
you're trying to make excuses yeah
you're scared and you don't want to say
you're scared to get a person to make
her come yeah hey I would love to make
you come but I'm too good a guy that
would fly with no one right now you're
using her you're using her for her mind
and you're not taking care of her body
not using her she is the mayor of
neglect City yes you're in a
relationship right I am you get that box
eaten more than once every four months
yes I do it for you
[ __ ] right good for you am Skippy
look here's what if you're all on a
[ __ ] first they like that look Sam just
try everything that you can possibly try
everything that you've seen in porno
movies all of it just try it on her do
it in a trusting way do it in a way that
you agree upon what kind of porn do you
watch [ __ ] what do you like 14 years
of Virgil's Aeneid just one per 10 so
most of it I would simply experience a
lot of pornography I'm on it yes your
inflections in raging yeah I liked him
at first and I was rooting for him to
lose his virginity but now I'm kind of
hoping we make it to 40 because he's
never he's never performed oral but he's
bragging about 14 years I've watched
quite a bit of porn in my time look
here's what you got to do yep just use
her for everything you've ever wondered
about the fact that she knows that
you've never gotten laid your virgin
you're all this and she's still
accepting of your mouth and dick and
balls like you have to practice
everything on her so that you can move
forward to the next girl and the next
girl and the next girl with actually
some kind of experience Sam that's the
best advice you yeah that's it because
you're not dating a 24-year old virgin
I'm not
you don't have time to see you're not a
teacher I've never taken anybody's
virginity that's how [ __ ] out him how
old that meet you actually how old is
your boyfriend he's 28
okay so that's the age appropriate he's
gotten laid before yes he has okay good
that's very handsome tall many times is
he a handsome tall guy yeah he does he's
done the sex thing before okay she
hooked up with Adrian I did but he
didn't get it in no he didn't wait did
you suck his penis no I didn't go down
you know but she licked your nipples
yeah he left my nipples are they nice
that big nipples are small okay so you
hooked up with Adrian why I gotta tell
you I [ __ ] love AIDS yeah awesome
like Cubans am show cuz I have an excuse
to text him I like was texting I'm like
hey you want to give me that snapchat
login also how are you it doesn't make
your boyfriend insecure I can't text him
otherwise because I have a boyfriend who
I love why didn't you suck his penis we
kind of did that like with clothes on
grinding things so it felt it felt like
it was there for sure yeah but I don't
know I didn't see it I would know if it
was why didn't he try why did he try to
get it not get it in what happened well
I just don't give it up that easy
oh I see I'm sorry I think he's try to
including it no no no I wouldn't let him
and also I knew because we were coming
back on Sam's show that I was gonna come
back on and talk about it I wasn't even
expecting to let him touch my boobies
but I did so that was generous that's
cool yeah [ __ ] yeah go ahead Adrian get
those nips so he didn't go down on you
my fault Adrian for that but he did kiss
the nipples that's cool but he should
have kept kissing this here's the thing
all right and also like Roxy can really
hold her liquor yeah so he had you had a
few drinks in him so she got him off his
game Allah oh he was a little drunk he
stopped trying into your stomach
[Music]
you did send me ribs after though like
to my door in LA he sent me ribs so
that's cooler than crying hey baby you
like dinner yeah baby you're hungry I
wish I could take you out for some ribs
yeah what a shame to send a woman this
one girl is my center mashed potatoes
maybe eggs the omelet you made in her
ass
no bash potatoes are really romantic see
when they're cold unless on your
doorstep they're an aphrodisiac make
hearts in them you know you could carve
[ __ ] that's exactly right
mashed potato art Nick in San Francisco
has a question for Sam in Virginia
what's going on Nick good yeah good
afternoon
oh good afternoon hello I guess it's a
test of the morning for us out here on
the west coast but it's almost that's
right over there
okay that's right so what I don't
understand is if you're a truck driver
which is so immersed you know in the
horror culture how do you make it to 24
without at least once getting curious
enough to buy out like I feel like Jim
Norton could only drive a truck about 50
yards before he pulled off the bile or
there's a lot quickly Jim Norton makes a
lot more money than I do and has access
to a lot better as you say [ __ ] than I
do I don't know if you've ever seen a
truck stop [ __ ] but it don't like scene
one I was raised by one Jim's mom the
truck stop [ __ ] that she is that's how
she made a living that's how the Nortons
got Christmas personally that's how she
put [ __ ] bread and penicillin on the
table right getting a mouthful of truck
driver yeah home with her hair messy
wearing a cat diesel fuel has vagina
looked the same where's the lesson here
that we're all vaginas are good enough
to eat she's um she looked disheveled
she'd have a cat
a dog should give your dad a big kiss on
the mouth she tasted like cigarette yes
don't know all right we're gonna take a
break
call us back on on Monday you know
you're gonna perform first of all get
your dick in there this weekend buddy
yes I'm back on your team yeah roll over
on your stomach and say look that little
place where the [ __ ] comes out I'd love
to fill it yeah try to have some sex
this weekend Sam okay wait you say to
yourself when you wake up in the morning
but this week a wife says to him I
didn't just wakes up but she goes it's
not gonna work
it's not gonna work calls back on Monday
okay buddy all right guys love this joke
Jimmy I Love You Man you're hilarious
like an dude all right thanks man
all right thank you good luck man we'll
talk to you later Roxy thank you for
stopping by thanks for having we always
learned so much from you